if later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend hey what's going on guys oh
it has been a tiring week and you guys
can tell by this hair that obviously
it's not the most fantastic thing you've
ever seen your [ __ ] life deal with it
oh if you're chilling in the coop office
space we've had a very very long day and
nobody else works just late but this is
a usual space that I work out and I run
out because I can't work at home it's
way too distracting like if I'm at my
bed most likely I'll jackoff or another
reason why I'm tired as you guys may or
may not know I started doing funny fat
Finnegan working on something that's
very difficult it's something I
absolutely [ __ ] hate like there's
some people who say like yeah they get
sore or they hate working out you have
to realize that I would I would very
much rather get shot in my ballsack to
work out sometimes that's just truth but
one of the things that are practicing
this [ __ ] when it comes to my weight
loss is a macro fitness so basically how
a macro daddy works is that you have a
set amount of calories you have a set
amount of fats carbs and proteins as
long as you hit those you will
technically I guess lose weight in a
very healthy way and for those you up
there in LA that don't know what my
tegami munzo is my tummy munzo is a
Japanese futon place and it is the [ __ ]
you know what the funny [ __ ] is about
the most authentic Asian restaurants in
LA is the fact that you can walk in
there and you will find out that this
authentic food is made by a bunch of
Mexicans and they do it better that's
not a thing on earth that a Mexican
can't do or build and [ __ ] take over
the world
hey ray what's your special recipe a
[ __ ] Mexican that's what it is damn
it but the great thing about modern
everyone's at once again is they're
fresh noodles now obviously when it
comes to noodles and when you're making
a certain type of food there's a certain
amount of craft to it quite a zombie
moans it not only has great food on
noodles they're flavor profiles are out
of this world now the way they kind of
approach food on is interesting because
they do have a lot of traditional
flavors but at the same time they come
at it with a lot of new ones that you've
never had before
Unni cream Mugen vongole you don't
potato bert and udon there's like all
these different flavors that i
personally never thought about putting
into this dish that they do and it's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and this week I didn't
really get to see some of the homies so
I wanted to see my friend Edgar Kinsey
you know a lot of the times I get so
caught up in my ride
the ideas that I'm producing that I
don't have to see a lot of my friends
now when you have a passion and it
becomes part of your work you become
that much more dedicated to it so
sometimes a lot of your social life
stuff just falls to the wayside now if
you guys don't know who educates er
educated obviously friends of mine
really close friends of mine actually
and we do a lot of music together
hendrik actually took me as one of the
most underrated rappers in LA ever gives
a very to say the least
fascinating character now if you look at
this dude's Instagram he's obviously
very artistic you'll see his stuff it
worries about composition in his photos
the whole black and white thing and he
really focuses on the art of the way his
Instagram and especially when it comes
to most music looks and feels so this
[ __ ] is one of the most lewd
[ __ ] I ever met in my life I
just know that whenever I have a
conversation with this man just know
he's gonna say something
absolutely lascivious Amen what you eat
today I just don't fan juicy [ __ ] you
know why you I've got golden man we
always just be having some nice
conversation be thrown out some
curveballs and [ __ ] you make me feel
weird
zi wood was actually there too and I'm
pretty sure you guys have seen him in my
acapella square videos in my Instagram
and if you guys don't know um he's
actually Swedish what's this order yeah
for sure he's
so my son using it every now and then
the dude corrects my English and I want
to sock him in the [ __ ] face actually
you guys want to know the most annoying
[ __ ] about Xia's this fool keeps on
trying to feed me this disgusting
Swedish candy called Black Kettle also
known as dingleberry sewers black
licorice not one no it tastes like a
[ __ ] butthole there I'll take two
that's just gross bad and they're super
dope being around edge again see because
as you can see know how to joke around a
little bit when edrick dyed his hair I
told the school you look like Ellen
DeGeneres so if you guys heard some of
my music Z is actually the one that has
been vocally producing over 98% of it
now for me of course I always wanted to
do music back in the day but I was at a
crossroads in my life where I had to
choose what I want to do either I was
gonna be a musician or I was gonna be a
comedian not to say that I can't do both
but when you tend to split yourself up
into multiple people you tend to live a
duplicitous life and when you do you
can't really focus on a single crap and
make it grow at a certain point I had to
let go music because I decided that I
wanted to be a full-fledged comedian I
am like nothing you have ever seen
before but being around musicians who
really work on their art and then craft
not just put out [ __ ] covers and just
copy everybody else's [ __ ] that really
work on their art has pushed me to
become a better artist myself and it
kind of sucks to I'm not sure if any of
you out there have really led one of
your passions died out but it's one of
those feelings that kind of hurts a bit
because your passion is a part of you
and for me when I met these guys and
especially Paul Kim which you guys
already know Paul Kim there's a whole
nother story about how he has influenced
my music and kind of put faith in me in
the sense that he helped me realize that
I actually you know I might have a gift
when it comes to my voice and I'm
letting you guys in on this part of my
life because it's pretty awesome how the
people that you're around directly
affect your productivity and how you
feel as a human being I know a lot of
you guys out there are very strong
individuals but you do also have to
realize that you do tend to become the
people that you're around if they are
not motivated if they don't push you to
be a better person than why even be
around them in the first place
and what you'll find out is that when
you're around people who are focused and
driven
you will become just like them and you
guys will grow together and the people
that don't grow with you they tend to be
the friends that fall to the wayside how
many of you out there have growing pains
where you left to another city you got a
new job and try to come back to these
old homies and when you have
conversations with them they just don't
understand you you don't understand what
they're talking about you guys don't
relate anymore and it's not in the sense
that you guys hate them or something
happened to the point where your
friendship just died is more like you
grew to be different people your goals
are different people that you hang with
a different man your mission in life is
different as well so exactly at the end
of the day what can you really relate to
besides stuff that you talk about your
past hopefully I'll be coming out with
some more music with you guys edges been
pushing me to put out a couple of songs
so hopefully y'all will see some [ __ ]
nothing necessary cuz you confuse my
heart girl your love and let every
thought it would be like this when a
good thing turns to [ __ ] that's too big
QB when he took aim with the arrow
should the missed I was trying to be a
pharaoh but you like hell no on your
Cleo [ __ ] had an answer to this cancer
when you turned into a chemo [ __ ] so
the signs in the